[Music]
the odds have been all over the place
for the
first
uh player taken who we don't know it
will be we know that trevor lawrence is
going number one overall we know that
zach wilson or at least we strongly
believe he's going number two overall
third overall pick in the draft the
favorite by slim margin continues to be
justin fields and mac jones then trey
lance who's fading a little bit so as we
play this game of what's more likely
what's more likely the 49ers were set on
their quarterback target when they trade
it up to number three or they won't
decide on who they're taking until next
week what's more likely and we mentioned
this because mike tannenbaum former nfl
gm right saying yes to all that he's
hearing that there isn't unanimity at
the top of the organization john lynch
adam peters kyle shanahan on what
they're going to do with that well it
doesn't it doesn't take unity what is
that word you know i can't even
inaudible yeah it doesn't take that
analyzation yeah right right my
analyzation of that team is there's a
king in charge and his name is kyle
shanahan so he makes the decision okay
that's what i would say there to that i
would
just be shocked right that
they were set on a qb target as far as
who they were thinking at number three
was it like a hundred percent i don't
know but my friend kyle shanahan is no
idiot i mean he's no idiot so i would
think he went up there with having one
guy
yes in mind but he wasn't just going to
be like all right let's close up shop
and not look at anything else i don't
want to you know i think he's he's a
smart guy he's going to continue to do
his homework and do his due diligence on
you know everybody
in this process but uh i i i would think
there's one guy in mind here to move up
to number three
and look you don't have to put it on
paper until you're on the clock and
i i guess
i guess you you could there's no reason
to say who it is if you do change your
mind you never know what's going to
happen you never know what could happen
yeah right happen between now and then
right something could happen slip and
fall in a bathtub i don't know but
something could happen between now and
then and and uh so why why make it clear
and obviously the nfl doesn't want
anyone to make it yeah yeah we've
already ruined the first two we don't
want to ruin number three right you're
right no i you know you're right you're
right about that and you know i think um
you know again all three of these guys
are really talented it does seem like
there's somebody whether it's lynch
or peters
somebody high up in that organization
it seems to like trey lance that that
seems to jump out to me because you hear
that name a lot i feel like more in nfl
circles than anything and even through
the media there and everything like that
so i don't know where where where it is
there but like i said i would just be
shocked if there wasn't one guy in mind
here to make that move to go up to
number three and i would think they know
who that is and they're just kind of
doing their homework
i don't know who pointed this out it may
have been peter king at some point in
the past week on the program may have
been you it all starts to blend together
for me but could they be holding out
hope to try to get the falcons if the
falcons are dead set on lance to the
point where they wouldn't take jones
they would take lance to do a a
flip-flop i i can't imagine that no i
can't
give up to get there you're not going to
risk not getting the guy you want yeah
no no i mean i to me like that then then
you would have to
i would you'd almost have to have like
okay we'll trade it with you but you
gotta guarantee you're gonna pick this
guy so our guy will be there i don't
know but yeah i don't envision that
happening and i think they they made a
play because they want a different
quarterback for the future that's what
they did jimmy g whether he hangs around
for one more year i would seriously
doubt that i would think that he gets
traded sometime between now and june or
july something there uh but they're
gonna pick you know a quarterback at
number three and and like i've always
said i'll be shocked if it's not mac
jones
superstar tight end kyle pitts what's
more likely he's drafted in the top five
or four quarterbacks are taken in the
top five oh likely this is a good all
comes down to the falcons yeah right
isn't it it is it's amazing i mean it
really is this is the the the spot right
here uh
i'm gonna say that they go the tight end
i mean pitts is awesome i mean he's
awesome
i've never really seen a tight end like
him
since i've been on this side of the
business and really been studying
players
coming out in the draft and doing all
that i mean to move the way he moves you
know you you can't cover him mike you
can't he can get open because he's got
great quickness and speed but even when
he's covered he's unbelievable at 50 50
balls back shoulders whatever it is i
mean it's it's really it's 80 20 it's 90
10. it's unbelievable
i mean he's got some of the best corners
in college football all over him
sometimes doesn't matter 20 yard gain
easy catch i mean he just makes it look
easy and then he can run after the catch
so i mean if i'm the falcons
that that's where i'm going you know you
got a quarterback that's still really
good in your hand right you know what's
your old saying you think you always say
you got a bird in the hand right i mean
they got somebody that i think has a few
years left
but to to
look for the future quarterback like i
just feel like that day's done that's
there's quarterbacks every year you can
make a move like shanahan did the 49ers
if you need a quarterback to get one in
the draft whatever i just don't think
you look that far down the road when you
got one that's got at least two three
real good years left in them
and i will underscore this port before
we move on and i know that there will be
people who disagree with me but i am
very very confident
that that call at four is gonna be made
by arthur blank he's not gonna mandate
he's not going to dictate right he's
gonna make it known he's got subtle ways
and not so subtle ways of making what he
wants known if he wants pits he's
getting pits if he wants lance he's
getting lance that's what it's going to
be and there may be no
no up up footprints or evidence or
anything but rest assured what blank
wants is what blank is going to get all
right what's more likely that bengals
take receiver jamar chase at number five
or tackle penney sewell
this chase the former joe burrow mate
the right sewell the future teammate who
could keep joe burrow on the field and
here here's the thing too that's
interesting about this they could play
it either way they really could with
these two positions
there's going to be a really good one
left at the top of the second
that's where i this is where it's a
tough decision it really is
you know i i i i'm going to say penny so
penny sewell but i don't feel confident
in that i still think there's got to be
a chance where the bangos look at this
and go wait joe burrow he's we know how
awesome this guy they got a special
connection and with those receivers and
joe mixon i mean you could really have
an elite skill group unit there if you
add jamar chase a number five there
i would go i would have to think that's
enticing them a little bit here uh so
it's interesting but i'm going to say
penny sewell as we sit here right now
but i don't feel totally confident about
that what about you what would you do i
feel more confident i i think it's going
to be sewell i think they were burned by
john rice or john ross excuse me yeah
four years ago the last guy taken before
patrick mahomes and he didn't work out
they've got receivers they can get more
receivers later in the draft i think
they go sewell let's take a break we'll
continue this game of what's more likely
when pft live continues right after this
all right we continue with what's more
likely the new york giants they
currently sit at number 11. they rarely
trade down as sheree williams pointed
out yesterday the last time they traded
down was with the steelers in 2006 when
the steelers drafted san antonio homes
the steeles like to draft up for the
guys they really like
the giants reportedly could trade down
so chris what's more likely they trade
down from number 11 or
they trade up into the top ten i think
it's trade down all the way this is
still a team that you know has got like
holes to fill
uh and and i i don't know
you know what would be there that's so
glaring as far as one guy that they need
right now that would be a top 10 talent
i mean you know maybe
a pass rusher but i think there's going
to be a good pass rusher probably
sitting there on the board at number 11.
the one thing that i continue to hear
from friends and people around the nfl
mike and i don't know if you've heard
this either the whole team the whole
draft is looking to trade down everybody
wants to trade down and accumulate picks
everybody or trade up straight down to
trading
we can just go ahead and supply all of
the reporting for the next eight days
insert name of team is considering
trading up and considering trading down
and considering using the pick that it
currently has well yeah
right well but i think we're really i
mean you're right we're gonna hear all
that bull crap but i think like really
because of the year and the
circumstances around it
you know
lack of information out there on some of
these players wait we haven't seen him
play football in two years
i there's i just i've heard this too
many times
there's there's too many teams not
comfortable with the draft this year you
know i think more teams that i talk to
they want to push draft picks in the
next year that's what they're looking
for next year where we feel better we
can vet these guys better we can meet
them we can go through more workouts and
and get more information on the guys all
of that so i would think trade down too
because again i think the giants
you know pass rusher
one thing you look at i don't know they
could certainly go offensive line you
know in that and that area and i would
think that there's going to be a good
one to trade down there if you get the
right you know
the right trade package that's still
available and for the giants what they
would want right is like
you you would hope that a fields or a
trey lance fell down there and now will
in new england a washington a chicago
want to trade up and get the quarterback
and you get a bevy of picks off of that
that would be ideal for for big blue
yeah and i like the point that teams are
going to be looking to pick up draft
picks next year
to address needs next year to better vet
next year and it creates an interesting
balance between
the coaches and the gm's who may not be
around next year that's how you find
that marriage
of a team that will trade up
and a team that will trade down the
teams with security trade down give me
the picks next year i can do a better
job of getting comfortable with who i'm
taking
coaches and gm's this year i gotta win
this year i gotta go all in i gotta roll
the dice and some of those moves may
work that's the thing it's a crap shoot
anyway it's crap shoot anyway yeah but
this is a year where you can roll the
dice and get lucky
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports